ever since Google Chrome came out in
2008 Yes dominated the market the
integration with Google services and
extensions has made it the go to browser
for most people but there are still some
people who use other browsers some of
these choices are self-explanatory for
example the second most popular desktop
browser is Safari which is not
surprising given that it comes
pre-installed on Mac the same thing can
be said about Microsoft Edge and
Internet Explorer as well but what about
Firefox Firefox currently controls 7.69
of the market and it doesn't come
pre-installed on Windows Mac or any
mobile device so people who are using
Firefox had to go out of their way to
get it and they chose it over chrome and
given that billions of people around the
world use PCS firefox's user base works
out to a total of 362 million users at
first it might be easy to write off the
segment as people who are anti-bake Tech
and anti-google but if you take a closer
look you'll see that this isn't just
some Google hate Club in fact there are
several subreddits that discuss why
Firefox is the best browser these people
aren't using Firefox because they don't
want to use Chrome they're using Firefox
because they want to use Firefox this
story becomes even more interesting when
you realize how Firefox is funded
Firefox is a non-profit organization and
they don't run ads or have any other
internet-based services so they're
virtually completely funded by donations
and at by far their largest donor is
actually Google in fact last year
Mozilla pulled in a total of a 500
million dollars out of which 450 million
came from Google before Google got
involved Mozilla was actually slashing
their Workforce and scaling back their
operations so in a way Google actually
saved Firefox when they could have just
let them die and absorb their market
share so here's why hundreds of millions
of people still use Firefox and why even
Google supports Firefox
to understand why people still use
Firefox we'll have to take a look back
at why people started using Firefox in
the first place taking a look back the
roots of Firefox actually dated back to
their early 1990s to a company called
Netscape a lot of you watching it may
not even be familiar with the Netscape
but back in the day they were by far the
most dominant internet browser but all
of this would change when Microsoft
launched Internet Explorer Internet
Explorer came bundled with windows so
when people bought new computers they
just started using Internet Explorer
instead Microsoft would actually end up
facing an Anti-Trust lawsuit for this
practice which almost split up the
company but that's a whole other story
anyway as Netscape continued to bleed
market share against Microsoft they
simply couldn't keep up the fight
Microsoft had an advantage in basically
every Avenue they had more brand
recognition more trust more developing
power and more marketing power so in a
last-ditch effort net Escape would try
to make their browser open source in
1998. the idea was that tens of
thousands of Open Source developers
could help them take on Microsoft they
codenamed the project Mozilla which was
a combination of the words Mosaic and
Godzilla and they were Off to the Races
or at least that's what they hoped for
in reality they would run into a bunch
of roadblocks for one the browser was a
rather complex for being an open source
project which heavily limited the number
of developers who could help out and
secondly Netscape couldn't even open
source much of the browser because a lot
of the code was licensed from third
parties they fumbled around like this
for several years but eventually in June
of 2002 they would make the hard
decision of scrapping everything and
starting from scratch initially the
project was called the Mozilla Phoenix
but this got them into trouble with the
buyer's manufacturer Phoenix
Technologies so they would switch their
name to Mozilla Firebird but this simply
created confusion with the database
software Firebird So eventually they
switched their name to Mozilla Firefox
and the first official release of the
browser came in February of 2004. while
Firefox faced quite a bit of challenges
in actually launching the first few
years after launch were actually rather
Smooth by 2008 Firefox would control 30
of the market and if it wasn't for
Chrome Firefox probably would have taken
majority control the reasoning for this
was quite simple Firefox was built off
the success and the back of Netscape
which was at one point the most popular
browser in the world Firefox was
essentially just a rebranded revamped
open source modern reboot of a Netscape
so choosing to use Firefox over the
rapidly aging Internet Explorer was a
rather easy choice not to mention the
public distaste for Microsoft was rather
High throughout the early 2000s as they
were seen as the evil Monopoly that you
might associate with the Google or
Facebook today but despite all this
progress Firefox would be stopped dead
in its tracks with the launch of Chrome
foreign
didn't launch with anything
groundbreaking per se it was basically
just Firefox but from Google with a few
little upgrades here and there for
example they embraced the idea of
sandboxing which made individual tabs
independent of each other this made it
so that if one tab crashed the entire
browser wouldn't crash tweaks like this
made Chrome marginally faster and more
stable than Firefox but this wasn't
anything that Firefox couldn't catch up
to catching up wouldn't really help
Firefox though because the speed and
stability weren't really the selling
factors of chrome while they definitely
made the experience better the real
selling factors were the Google
ecosystem and developer support starting
off with the Google ecosystem this is
self-explanatory Chrome beautifully
integrated with the Gmail accounts
Google Maps Google Drive Google's office
products and of course google.com itself
and it's kind of similar to the whole
Apple ecosystem with iCloud iMessage and
apple music as people became more
reliant on Google's various Services
they tended to switch to Chrome but it
wasn't just users who prefer to Chrome
either developers were also big fans of
chroma because it was a build with the
developers in mind Chrome was built
around the standards of HTML5 and it
even passed the acid 1 and asset 2 tests
from day one if you're not familiar with
these tests they're basically just a way
of gauging how well a particular browser
can display aspects of HTML anyway as
developers started jumping onto their
Chrome bandwagon websites became more
and more optimized for Chrome and pretty
soon it got to the point that if you
wanted the best browser experience you
used chrome Firefox was never that far
behind it but for the average person
there was really no reason to ever
choose Firefox over chrome this was only
made it worse by Google's marketing
power Google didn't even need to pay
anyone to Market Chrome they could just
advertise Chrome across all of their
existing services for free and that's
exactly what they did in the meantime
Firefox it didn't do much to
differentiate themselves so they
basically became an open source version
of Chrome we should also mention that
many parts of chrome itself were already
open source so that wasn't a very big
Advantage for Firefox either with all
the cards stacked against Firefox they
inevitably started losing market share
year after year bringing us to where we
are today
if Chrome is so good why do people still
use Firefox well there's actually
several legitimate reasons for this
starting with computational requirements
it may not seem like it but Chrome is
actually rather computationally intense
especially for being a browser remember
how we talked about how Chrome treats
each tab separately well it turns out
that this requires a bunch of ram
Firefox does this to an extent as well
but they limit the number of processes
to sticks at a time so if you have 20
tabs open on Chrome you'll have 20 Ram
processes but if you open 20 tabs on
Firefox you'll only have 6 gram
processes which is much kinder to low
respect devices aside from offering
better support for lower spec devices
Firefox also offers better support for
older operating systems for example
Chrome is dropping support for Windows 7
in February of 2023 which doesn't make
any sense while it has been 13 years
since the launch of Windows 7 it was
still the second the most popular
operating system in the world as of the
end of 2020 so you would think that
Google would continue pouring some money
into Windows 7 support but that doesn't
seem to be the case now to be fair
firefox's extended Support also ends
around the same time but if neither of
them support your OS it makes more sense
to go with the browser that's friendlier
to older computers with lower specs
moving on from performance related
benefits we have privacy benefits it's
no secret that Google makes most of
their money by collecting your data and
serving relevant ads Firefox on the
other hand is a non-profit and doesn't
track your browsing history by default
Firefox also blocks cookies and they
generally have substantially better
privacy features than Google given that
they don't have anything to gain from
making these policies loose now it
should be noted that Firefox does not
wipe out data collection altogether if
you go to google.com on Firefox Google
can still collect a bunch of data but if
you use Firefox in combination with
something like duckduckgoa then you
actually have a chance at protecting
your privacy but all of this brings up
the question if Firefox is a competitor
to Google and they're actively working
to reduce how much data companies like
Google can collect why in the world is
Google funding Firefox
well the official answer is so that
Google can be the default search engine
on Firefox but this doesn't make a whole
lot of sense first of all if a
significant portion of Firefox users are
going out of their way to use Firefox
over chrome I bet that they're also
likely to go out of their way to use a
different search engine over Google and
secondly if Google were to stop
supporting Firefox then Firefox would
likely just lose market share which
Google can absorb so it seems like the
play for Google would be to just pull
the plug on Firefox and increase their
own market share so why don't they do
this well the answer is to protect their
Monopoly here's the thing regardless of
whether Google controls Firefox and
market share or not Chrome is already a
monopoly I mean they control 77 of the
market so either way they'd be a
monopoly but if they eliminated Firefox
they'd be a monopoly at risk right now
when an Anti-Trust Regulators question
them they have some plausible
deniability with fire Firefox they can
talk about how they're single-handedly
holding up this open source project and
how they're encouraging competition if
they were to let Firefox die however
that case wouldn't be nearly as strong
at the end of the day the initial
popularity of Firefox can be attributed
to its roots in Netscape and its
superiority to Internet Explorer but
with the launch of chrome and the growth
of the Google ecosystem people have
chosen Chrome over Firefox by far
nonetheless a non-negligible portion of
the population it still uses Firefox
because it often works better with older
computers and operating systems it's
open source and into way more privacy
driven and for the first time Firefox is
actually starting to lean into its
differences like its privacy features
instead of just being an open source
Chrome and as people become more
conscious of data privacy we may just
see another surge in Firefox popularity
but we'll just have to wait and see
what's your favorite browser and why
comment that down below also drop a like
if you would like for Chrome to see some
serious competition and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community suggested video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one